and you heard the president at the very
last moment there take a swipe at the
Republicans they're saying there's a
faction of the GOP that's ruining the
whole conversation and turning this
political season into the silly Paula
and into the silly season so tonight
we've got the debate uh you know he said
you know he set up the Democrats there
with you know with this debate so what
do you is anything going to stop Donald
Trump here tonight I don't think so I
think Donald has two arguments which
resonate with the public one of those is
that immigration is dampening wage
growth and there probably is some truth
to that if you have an unlimited supply
of labor it's unlike that wages are
gonna grow as fast as they could if the
supply was restricted and the second
he's showing his willingness to tax
successful investors to tax the rich and
so I think those two arguments would
made an agreement with the president
there on zombie didn't agree with Bernie
Sanders too I mean they're almost
identical in their position so I think
he can capture the same percentage of
the Republican side as he can from the
Democratic side if he was running as a
Democrat my biggest fear is this things
that if he wins the Republican primary
he can't really win as a Republican but
his fix of that problem is to become a
Democrat and then only we won't have a
Republican running will basically have
two Democrats because he'll be talking
about raising tax rates and closing the
border to immigration which will slow
down our economy and so will the higher
tax rates but he'll nevertheless be
proposing it because he'd get a high
share of the vote with that position how
is it possible that he gets a high share
of the vote with those positions from
the Republican electorate I think he's
gonna have a hard time winning the
Republican primary but why is he even
polling in such substantial numbers up
there's a large two things there's one
is this large protest by three things
but one is this large protest vote on
both sides of the aisle there's largest
vote for nobody and that enzyme so it's
coalesce around and Carson Carson okay
but in the and on the other side the
mainstream Republicans are still
fragmented so there's been no PO
coalescing to a candidate who can
compete the second is Donald is a
reckless showman that makes great TV
everybody wants to see what crazy thing
you might do that draws a large audience
and then he uses as our media to
diminish the other candidates and the
other candidates are reluctant to
wrestle with the pig because you get
dirty and the pig likes it so they stand
back on the sidelines so he's getting
all the attention pouring negative
advertising on to the other candidates
diminishing them and it's working but by
the time we get to the primaries they're
going to pour millions of dollars into
diminishing him and they won't attack
him for what seems like emotional
instability and the reckless comments
that he makes about the women after what
was a attack attack him on being a
Democrat he's been for higher taxes he's
been for broadening more spending in
health care lots of positions that he's
taken in the past so it will come back
to haunt him when they start pouring
millions of dollars you don't actually
believe the poet you don't actually
believe the polls that say Donald Trump
is is you know for lack of a better word
trumping the other candidates right now
you say online online betting is more
accurate and in that sense jeb Bush's is
a online betting although the volumes on
online betting are still small they
haven't really heated up yet but
historically they've been way more
accurate than the polling which is
highly inaccurate at this point in the
race I mean I think Rick Perry was
winning at this point four years ago
when when President Obama was a
candidate for the Democratic nomination
against Hillary Clinton at this time
during that original yeah I marry
Hillary Clinton was ahead of aim same
thing Morocco but I think online betting
bushes at thirty-five percent and Donald
Trump is that fifteen percent so almost
more than to do you take that bet I
think I would take that bet and I think
right now the internet if you look at
the volume on the internet it's far more
willing to take the bet against bush so
there seems to be money out there on the
internet betting they want to bet on
Bush because they think the odds are
undervalued on bushing overvalued on
Trump